good morning Millennials I don't even
have the energy to to wish our
Millennials good morning but do you
think that doing good morning
Millennials gives you energy because it
just made me smile let's try
good morning Millennials it's like dry
and FEC it's a 5-hour energy kind of
thing you're all about the five ever
writers I just feel like oh like if it
works like how they say it works like I
would be down and I feel like I'm the
perfect candidate I'm always tired I'm
like literally awake in production five
hours of the day and then I go back to
sleep like if you took one after your
show tonight at 11:00 you'd be out
partying till 4:00 and you go to sleep
great night guys if you're watching this
and you were at the show last night
literally you guys were so lit like the
shows were incredible the shows were
incredible but only because like the
audience it was literally like a rave no
it was like it was wild it was like
Spring Break um ya know the people were
insane like I know a lot of people like
came by themselves and like met people
at their table and like literally made
like lifelong friends like it was
literally like a sorority that's what it
is it was so fun it was like so epic and
like I was so excited to like be doing
it again and I'm really excited for
tonight two more shows tonight 7 o'clock
at 9:30 I really can't wait to see you
guys there me too sorry tickets are sold
out like can't really get to go can't
wait to see the greatest comic of our
time I really hope Amy Schumer comes and
like steals the stage her ring you
should invite her I was Lee I'm her yeah
I heard you could use some stage time I
have it all at Caroline's I feel like
she would have liked that okay then say
it nicer okay okay um anyways it's
Friday and we're just so happy and uh
something that you know we talk about a
lot is the four-day workweek
mm-hmm and we are not practicing what we
preach no and like I did a whole thing
about it in my shell lesson and I'm
still not practicing what I dream she's
just like I really was hoping during the
show last night that you were gonna
cancel today's show just on the spot I
mean but it wouldn't be fair to like all
millions of you who weren't at the show
I cancelled emotionally like if you take
a look at my outfit I've dog hair all
over me and like I couldn't care less
that's a great shirt though it's Ben's
dad's actually Ben's dad yeah Hey Bruce
great shirt anyways but I think that we
said starting after Memorial Day weekend
once summer officially starts the
four-day Work Week is in place
because it's one thing to talk about
something but it's another thing to put
you know to action to do it and I just
feel like we're being frauds by just
talking about something and not actually
doing it because you have to be in order
to to enact change you have to be a
leader I need to lead by example that's
what we're doing practice what you
preach guys so this is our second to
last Friday
oh my god morally weakened so soon I
know we need to make puns yeah I have no
pants
we need plans okay without further ado
let's get into the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast because they're actually really
well-rounded and Oh like it's a slow
news day hmm
but a lot but a lot happened first of
all Bell had even the weekend kiss at
the Cannes Film Festival after denying
they're back together we have the photo
that has been seen around the world and
like honestly it's making me realize
something it's the day of realizing
stuff yeah they're really meant to be
together and like he knows a lot of like
his life to her cause like no one really
took him like serious he invented him
and like no one really thought he was
hot like until she dated him she Lena
Gomez would have never dated him if
Bella hadn't dated him first she
invented him in terms of like being a
bachelor before that he was just like a
weird guy who made good music yeah and
there were tons of those out there and
he was like a little chubby - yeah and
like hiding behind his hair like now he
has like confident huh so Bella totally
did that for him and she's like in love
with him like you remember that picture
of her on the Victoria's Secret airplane
where someone caught a picture of them
in her snapchat and she's like literally
sitting on the plane staring at a
picture of her enable legacy that was so
sad she's in love with him and like
honestly like she's like literally the
most beautiful girl in the world and she
just likes him so like what why he why
they can't work it out is beyond me well
maybe they can now but I really I like
them together a lot I just think it's so
crazy that his name is Abel like Cain
and Abel that's crazy
okay so despite so biblical despite
denying that they're back together the
weekend in Bella Hadid responded getting
cozy at the Cannes Film Festival I can't
believe it's ready can I can I come I
can't believe that it's already can't
tell strucker's there Ken goes on for so
long
yes because it's like the Cannes Film
Festival and then like the fake ad
festival that like Ken lion yeah they're
like people we know go to yeah the duo's
photograph sherry and kiss while at an
after-party and Ken France on Thursday
night after less than a month after they
both shot down rumors that they were
dating again that was at Coachella
when enews said that he was making out
with her Coachella and it was actually
it was Chantal Jeffries
crazy how they can just bounce back from
that like never happened also like like
he never what dated Selena Gomez her
friend no like that is like the betrayal
of a lifetime yeah but she forgave him
because she's so forgiving no because
she's literally obsessed with him yeah
in the photographs the pair is seen in
deep conversation with a d21 leaning in
to whisper something into the singer's
ear seemingly ignoring the partygoers
around them the two arrived separately
at the Magnum Alexander Wang party but
quickly huddled together for the rest of
the night in the VIP area according to
the Los Angeles Times don't they have
like better things to report yeah I am
honestly like I just think they're
they're made for each other and I'm
really happy that they're happy I hope
that this means that they're back
together because what I'm learning now
is like just because two people are seen
together doesn't mean they're a couple
Haley Mendez she'll be telling them this
period Haley mendes shawn baldwin like
but they kissed also these two yeah I'm
kissing God you know know for sure like
it could have been a drunk makeout
that's so crazy about celebrity culture
it's like it's two people are seen
hooking up we're supposed to believe
that they're dating but like in the real
world that's not true no but it's like
if they're brazen enough to hook up in
public it's because they've done it a
bunch before and are probably together
yeah it's just like the rules of
celebrity are different than the rules
of non celebrity and I much rather live
in the world of celebrity totally but no
one seems to be letting me in um I just
I hope I wish good things for the two of
them together on their own
you know but like their families are
insane it's crazy because like he really
loves Bella hoodie and I don't think he
has time for felfela no and I think like
once they broke up she really kind of
leaned into her fellow for feed
alter-ego and he wasn't herself you know
she really liked the girl that dated
Abel like two years ago is like
literally looks like nothing like the
girl that we know now
yeah and I'm hoping she'll kind of
revert back to that like fresh young
like Russian hooker luck totally the
pictures of them from the Met Gala two
years ago or just divine I know also
it's like so crazy how like he like uses
the Met Gala like the him and Selena
also like that was epic also that was
insanity so a two years in a row retail
purse yeah she looked amazing that year
yeah so it's just funny how like every
year he was how things change how things
could change any year actually years a
[ __ ] long time that's true yeah yours
like really a year it feels like a year
what I think
a year from today ago like wow that
really feels like a year ago
okay well it's May yeah but you know I
have like really bad amnesia and I don't
even know what happened last year where
we last May it was like right after
stagecoach we had just started the toast
we were like still on our janky white
tusks yeah we were having a good time
yeah oh so much Canary Oh best time we
always have the best time okay this next
story is kind of really sad and I just
don't understand how this keeps
happening but Rihanna's LA home was
burglarized and the suspect allegedly
stayed the night oh my god like
seriously this harkens back to something
I heard in Kanye's interview with
Charlemagne and we never actually spoke
about that interview on this show we
spoke about it on our patreon oh really
okay and he said something so profound
he was like you know it's really scary
how like you're you become just as
famous if not more famous than like the
president but you don't have like
national security secret service to like
hook you up so you're in charge of
you're on your own it's like really
scary
yeah so like not that I understand why
this keeps happening but like it's
really sad it is really sad the LAPD
says an individual who TMZ reports
appeared to have spent the night in the
singer's residence was arrested and
booked on residential burglary and
trespassing police were allegedly
notified to the intruder after her alarm
system was thought to have been tampered
with according to the outlet Rihanna was
not home during the incident in August
2017 the nine-time Grammy winner
purchased her la home for 6.8 million
dollars the contemporary-style estate
which is seven thousand one hundred and
thirty square feet okay this brought me
to get their word count in yeah
sit down close to half an acre
overlooking the Sunset Strip okay this
is the thing if you're a celebrity with
multiple homes and I only have one home
and I rent it something like I can't
really relate to this but if you have
multiple homes that you own and you're
like not in one of the homes do you not
have like a security guard there I don't
know about a guard but like what about a
security system where like it just goes
full fortress mode when something's
touch like gates come down alarms go off
like no totally like but you know
machines aren't only like they're never
as good as humans like if there was one
person there to catch this guy like
literally standing in front of the front
door like if I know that a celebrity is
out of town and their home is completely
empty of course I'm gonna try and break
in if I'm like up a burglar yeah I don't
I just feel like leave leave a Pascal
there like one person I don't know
that's kind of
waste of funds because like what no a
waste of funds is getting burglarized
that's sure I wonder what they took
I kept thinking Michael Richards I know
he's so sad it's so sad also after we
spoke about that on the show I we spoke
about The Bling Ring I wound up watching
just the beginning because really your
time I had to go and it is just a
masterpiece and it's literally so crazy
those kids like hopped Power Cells and
spends not even wearing a mask or
anything just walked right in no they
were sober but that's one thing I caught
up that's true like that's why they
never caught Kyle Richards burglars like
they wore masks
did they I'm assuming I'm assumed I just
can't believe and like how the LAPD
isn't all on top of this like it's just
the LAPD details was just like once a
week
right so you they should have like a
better system in place or like no this
thievery ring is also like it seems this
is where celebrities should live in New
York sorry seems like there's a new
bling ring yeah there's been a lot of
alarms recently that's true I think they
should go directly to the source Alexis
Neiers yeah DM her on Instagram I just
started following her answer and be like
hey Alexis
this is Nancy Jo do you know LT Joe this
is Alexis I mean is so crazy the mom is
out of control like she's fine $29 oh
man I wonder if anybody start about some
pretty wild after last week's episode
you guys
me and Jackie like before I went before
I go and say check I get really nervous
and like I really think that like the
best way to like channel nerves is to
pray because like there's literally
nothing else you could do and I'm just
like praying to stopping their wrist so
when all the sisters in the room we like
to like a little like huddle but like
it's not Catholic it's like Jewish it's
just like we just like pray prayerful
and then every time we like and it
Jackie's like and so it is and you know
what you did great last night so maybe
we had the Neyers energy with us we
respected I really feel bad for Rihanna
meet you but I also don't because I'm
sure she as long as like she's fine
everyone's fine I feel like she's the
type of person that like has her
priorities in order and knows that like
material things like she could just put
out an album and replace everything so
for sure but like I know people say
material items have no like bearing
whatever but like they're important
break3 morning they're there are
something like and also you know you buy
something that was like significant I
was like oh I got a platinum album
by myself this it's that stolen it just
kind of takes away the memory the
specialness yes but I just feel like
Rihanna specifically is above it up
above all material yeah that's
everything I mean and I don't really see
Madonna a Madonna I mean Mariana I don't
really see Rihanna as being like a
labels hoard you know I mean she's like
she's too good for us she just wears
whatever the hell she wants
speaking of Rihanna someone at the mean
greet bought me brought me a gift like a
bag of spent e products from Sephora
wait that's so nice I know like I can't
wait you did you get that purple and
orange I think I think be good I have to
open it it was so nice like I just left
in the box and I did my makeup like an
absolute savage today because I'm
exhausted from last night so I didn't
want to like waste it maybe I'll use it
for tonight shows oh my god
if you use that purple and orange thing
I want to go get it me too no I will
never use the color orange on my face
no but purple is cute purple is cute
orange for you especially
could you imagine gold Kara a makeup
tutorial where like I do everything that
like horrible like choosing colors that
were not meant for me okay just to show
you what not to do like red eye shadow
except I did red eye shadow when I was
shell blossom for Halloween I actually
looked amazing oh it is more of a
burgundy mmm like every room yes like a
coal hey Marie okay this next story is
really crazy and it's more of them like
a what the water they call it like a
thought piece okay so I'm just gonna get
on bed an op-ed from page six and it's
an exclusive and the title is hookers
Harvey and Americans missing from can
this year at the can film that you can
like take a back seat maybe have it now
because this is gonna be a long ride my
phone at the Cannes Film Festival this
year notable players are missing Harvey
Weinstein Graydon Carter Charles Finch
and dot about hookers in a year with
fewer US films and less stars a
Hollywood insider and Ken told page six
on Thursday quote I went to the do cap
for a drink no one was there not even
the hookers there are not a lot of
Americans there are not a lot of stars
the hookers didn't even come the player
was referring to to the hotel dekap Eden
Roc where stars and top execs stay and
where Weinstein once ruled the roost
once ruled the roost before his downfall
when we asked the insider if the absence
of ladies of the evening could be
because Weinstein isn't at the best the
source simply says
they say he never paid yes who's giving
the movie roles totally a bartender at
the hotel's bar Bellini told The
Hollywood Reporter last year when the
Weinstein scandal broke he was always in
here with one or two young girls very
loud but we are always polite because he
is a guest and the same story is
chauffeur further alleged that Weinstein
once brought a hooker back-to-back to a
room at the hotel
while his pregnant wife was in another
room which O'Brien's scene rep tonight
at the time sade baderinwa to be clear
Carter and Finch's reputations remain
unblemished and their can absences are
scandal free for now but they've taken
away two of the top-tier to cap parties
with them banned Affairs forgoing its
perennial star studded batching I'll
well this is a mouthful you guys do well
Finch and partners I'm well a lists will
make your centres also taking a year off
former Vanity Fair editor Carter is
elsewhere in France on quote gardening
leaf and Finch is busy launching a new
product called drugstore culture okay
whatever the big doozy here is that the
hookers aren't it can wait
we know can to be like hooker central
and they can go on a yacht and like it's
taken care of right and I think Han Film
Festival's actually started as a hub for
hookers and like a prostitution ring
yeah and then it just renamed like a
film festival because all of these
important people were there together
right we're like let's show our movies
but I don't really think that like just
because like what are the biggest
clients it's like out of business like
all the hookers didn't come like there's
still people who need hookers totally
but maybe they've gone underground
because like they don't want to end up
it was to spoken about yeah and like the
people who are paying for hookers like
don't want to Harvey mines right do you
know about the hookers like it's it's
overexposed you know and if we know
about the hookers I would hope that like
Interpol is there you know kind of
cracking down on the hookers didn't can
what's Interpol French please oh you
know like if we know about it yeah no
for sure and it's illegal activity
hopefully like the police are there I
just wonder it's like any like people
who are famous now like started out as a
hooker and can because if Harvey wasn't
paying the girls he was giving them like
stardom in return how far can you go
like based off of one can experience you
know Nemean yeah I just be really
curious to know like who got their
genesis in can in a hotel room ivy
very curious to know also someone said
it's a thought piece uh ah Thank You
Jules Lunetta that's a good one it is
about peace I'm very sorry I'm very
grateful though for like less can
content because it's such [ __ ]
oh my god it's the fakest thing ever and
like so fake it's so big and like
honestly like it's like the most like
what's sort I'm looking for like the
most weeny famous people go like not
even the cool famous people like it's a
mixture it's like serious people like
[ __ ] Kristen Stewart and Keira
Knightley like that's not really who I
want to say who do you want to see I
want to see like the Kardashians me then
nice job then like people can't or don't
come yet
and they go on a boat yeah actually
Kendall gets to go to a lot of the
things because she's a model and she
like does Julie like Bella is always
well that's where she is yeah okay but
the weekend like modelling jewelry on
the red carpet like yeah how that makes
money I'll never know no the way that
people make money is like so confusing
because when people say that about us -
Oh totally but it I mean it really is so
crazy but okay so she wears jewelry on
the red carpet and is paid to be there
is what I believe yeah and also like
okay so who's making money at can uh the
hotels okay who's paying for can put
bread who pays for that carpet like to
be put down like I don't know that
whoever runs this like hooker ring yeah
no it's just beyond confusing it's so
confusing and it all comes back to
hookers I'm telling you always and
always like two yachts totally but then
it's like Kourtney and Kendall are
always on yachts but I feel like they
think they're rich enough they paid for
their own yeah yeah I feel like they
just really like being in can yeah like
with all they want to be where it's cool
and like if you're gonna hook you're not
gonna do it with your sister that's
disgust a total no and Simon was there
and he just said they'd like have the
best time and they like go and hang out
it honestly looks like that's I mean
that's where they took those pictures
and those Legally Blonde yes it's
amazing okay well to everyone who can
please explain what's going on yeah
I would like a full PowerPoint I'm like
how who's making money who's paying for
things and like what the general like
economics it's a film festival
it's an organization that organization
needs to be looked into yeah totally
Interpol okay this next story is some
great news southern charm star Naomi o
Lindo has a new doctor boyfriend so I
love a good doctor boyfriend and I love
a good Naomi me too
a doctor has stole Naomi Oh Linda's
heart that's amount of complete sentence
stolen stolen after revealing her new
man on Instagram last month the southern
term Beauty confirmed to people she is
currently smitten with matul sha a
Charleston based anesthesiologist quote
I'm very very happy o Lindo 25 gushed
he's wonderful after splitting from
co-star Craig Conover in September after
three years of dating oh Linda said she
learned her lesson the hard way about
putting a relationship in the spotlight
we definitely both wish each other the
best we understand why I didn't work out
and it's time to move on and just be
happy for each other it's a good thing
oh Linda said about her ex has forked
over he plans to keep his next
relationship very much under the radar
I'm pretty sure the next relationship on
and no one will know about it for a
while he told page six I kind of want
that relationship that people know of
but know nothing about I'm not rushing
into anything I'm just kind of living
for myself again which is really nice
and it's been really healthy I've
accomplished more in the last few months
than I did in the whole year this this
pleases me on so many levels so do I
like them both separately much like and
I wanted them to be the other and even
watching the show it's like I want them
to reconcile then they talk and then
it's like I see why they're not together
and I still want the best for each of
them and it sounds like each of them has
found the best for yourselves no it's a
major step a possible scenario like for
for Naomi like going from like a
seamstress to a doctor tada like it's
just good for her
I'm sure her mom was really proud of her
and she looks amazing with this photo
this well yeah and she got a nose job
and like she's cool about it like I like
when people like don't beat around the
bush to get it like I know so change it
good for you but her doctor recently on
Instagram today i side by side and it
was like major and it was amazing work
great great advertisement for the doctor
but he did such a good job like if I
were to get a nose job I would probably
go to him but it's so interesting I like
some people get a nose job and it
doesn't really change the way that they
look or completely transform them
transforms them into a new person like
she looks so different you think so hmm
I like didn't think she looks so
different but I also don't notice
like that I'm like very oblivious no no
it's like a like a different pretty girl
do you not I mean she was put before
she's pretty now but like just a
different girl and like when I first saw
a picture of her after it I was like I
knew something was changed did you yeah
oh my god I really like Carrie Underwood
that [ __ ] looks so different I still
don't think so like sorry it's so
obvious one of the toasters put a text
message conversation with their mom in
the group or their moms like going off
without carrying on to read she's like
if I hear one more thing about her face
she looks beautiful she has more money
for plastic surgeons and she knows what
to do with it was like so funny and true
no to a totally Joe and like I'm not
really sure on like the the validity of
the story of like what happened that she
fell down the stairs I don't know is she
so happy for Naomi I'm so accepting to
film probably southern charm again in
the fall actually in such a long time so
never mind but it seems like everyone's
in a good place she was posting pictures
on Instagram with that thirst monster
general who went on relationship moves
like so no she's cool oh you didn't meet
her she's from the city she stayed in
the city but this girl who were was
working on Vanderpump dogs went on
relationship he moved the girls to
Charleston for a few weeks
she moved permanently to Charleston and
I was hooking up with the cast members
on southern terminus on the show what's
her name Peyton that's so [ __ ]
annoying and so Naomi called her out
last week on the show she's like you are
thirsty as [ __ ] good because that's so
thirsty like you and someone found like
an old facebook status of hers where
she's watching southern terms she's like
Craig and Shepard the cutest like it's
so embarrassing
oh my god that's horrible so but anyways
and I saw on Instagram that Naomi spends
with her mouth so I just can't keep up I
know honestly like I need to turn around
this time lapse between like where we
are now and where we're watching the
show is like for all Bravo shows
especially they've been apparels people
who are really like on social media is
really difficult it's it's too much and
it's like I want them to be filming
right now yeah I want to see what
happens when they were all drinking at
saltwater cowboys yeah
anyways fifth and final story is a doozy
you guys very complex look at energy
level right now is out of control and I
know you're picking up the slack for me
because I'm illiterate like I haven't
moved since we started my elbows in the
same exact position like I'm [ __ ]
exhausted like thank you
you're welcome sister it's it's a
give-and-take it truly truly is look I'm
never gonna move this elbow again I
think my hand has actually gotten um I
don't have my hand from the side either
I can't you look very comfortable Chum I
do this oh it's it likes or actually not
well okay really I'm not well
entertaining for all these people you're
such an entertainer I'm the greatest
showman gonna say that really show woman
you're you invented show business for on
42nd Street hear the sound of marching
feet
oh you having Hugh I'm taking you to
42nd Street I like the snaps we need
shoes jazz I feel like Bryan from high
school musical
I feel like chirping sharp I would never
wear this outfit okay sharp a would do a
show on the set a sharp a at a web show
oh yeah
sharp a would you wish you on the set a
fancy Beauty would do a show on this
everyone has been using our cell there
was one more he was someone sending to
me he was like champion champion
yeah like or one of those brands it was
crazy like pink backdrop with palm trees
is all the rage these days yeah hot men
by the way we really did it like I I had
no inspiration we thought we were
getting ferns yeah no like I was like
what wait what color back trap we're
like pink where they get purple no okay
pink and then like someone was like you
need some dick Lesage right okay ferns
I literally googled like fake tree on
Amazon and all right they're 40 bucks I
really recommend them I want to take one
for my house you should get one for your
apartment I need some good flake fake
flowers I'm just looking online
yesterday Joss and main okay I got some
from Wayfarer and I really like them and
I got like so much [ __ ] on social media
like I apparently like soap flowers are
like tacky as [ __ ] but these are fake
flowers and they're beautiful
no I'm just it's not about the ones I
have are beautiful too but just like the
concept is like a really frowned upon
but like I don't think anyone's frowning
upon these bad boys okay this is a set
not a home oh that's true I did she go
to treat her jasmine flowers from Trader
Joe's they're so cheap and they lost
forever I went to eat
Allen when I was starting out on this
home decor journey and they had
beautiful fake flowers and I don't think
those are found a pound I'm just letting
you know the concept swept to lie and
say like I'm allergic to flowers so
people like to tell me give me [ __ ] for
like be cheap and not wanting to keep
replenishing flour blame it all on Thea
when enjoyment on the tip good to you
okay this last story is crazy you guys
and everyone has an opinion about it so
you know those who also Busy Philipps is
upset after Vigo we're live tweets get
Greta Gerwig watching I feel pretty okay
wait just side note what we found out
this morning is even more shocking from
Jacob is that the girl who live tweeted
which will be read to all the tweets
she's the same girl who came up with the
conspiracy theory that Lea Michele he's
illiterate he's illiterate her name is
Jay Hunt and she has a podcast so I
automatically have respect for her and
her tweets even though that didn't even
change how I felt about this story but
it just gave it a little bit more
gravitas gravitas yes Busy Philipps has
started an important conversation about
privacy okay that part's not true
moviegoer live tweeted Greta Gerwig
watching I feel pretty on Wednesday
afternoon Twitter user hey Jun the
person who started the conspiracy maybe
that is true about Lea Michele being
illiterate shared with followers that
the Oscar nominated writer and director
Greta Gerwig sat down in front of them
at the movie theater quote um I'm in a
movie theater about to see I feel pretty
and Greta Gerwig just walked in and sat
down in front of me the tweet reads the
Twitter user J hunt then went on to live
tweet her wigs reaction to the movie
quote she just loudly pointed out a plot
hole and someone chest her one tweet
reads well another one says that girl
went quote full volume at the quietest
movie of the climax of the movie at the
quietest moment of the climax of the
movie quote this movie is
incomprehensible she said okay Greta
there's all these tweets basically after
reading the tweets girl wakes pal and I
feel pretty Starr Phillips Busy Philipps
reacted on her Instagram story so busy
saw these live tweets of Greta Gerwig
her friend like being so obnoxious in
the movie and saying like that things
about her movie and she said guys if you
see this woman that like live tweeted
Greta watching I feel pretty I mean
she's pretty [ __ ] mean about the
movie but that's not my issue
necessarily I mean that does suck
especially because Greta is our friend
she goes on to explain that that what
struck her the most is that we might be
at this point where we're just like
exists quote we're just like everybody
this for my own personal law okay shut
up HS alums me out on such a deep
personal level oh my god I'm getting a
colony no it's like for a delivery pick
it up and I need to cord pick it up
pretty right hello hi um can I call you
back a little later so is this number
the best she's so awkward in like [ __ ]
like this okay thank you bye
see gallery okay I don't want to [ __ ]
with Z Gallerie no okay see justice hell
Greta girl this is you things one I
would literally invite anyone to the
death that has anything to say about I
feel pretty because it's the greatest
movie in life and I'll fight someone and
it's like if we didn't like Greta Gerwig
already like anyone who doesn't like I
feel pretty is not a friend of no
totally and then to like Busy Philipps
is just making excuses for cutter girl
because they're friends if this was
another celebrity Busy Philipps loves
controversy she thrives she's an inch
she's a glorified Instagram her so like
she would have liked loved to have start
a fight but because it's her friend
she's not making a whole conversation
about privacy like no you're a celebrity
going to the movies and you're friends
with people in the movie and you're
being extra is how talking during like
it's not like she wore a hood and was
trying to hide even if a regular person
did that I'm pretty sure someone would
have waited [ __ ] in front of me in the
movie is being extra is how I'm talking
about her thoughts when literally nobody
cares Greta Gerwig like wants people to
hear her opinion oh she came in there
like I was an attention [ __ ] so I'm
glad she was exposed I'm glad I got back
to Busy Philipps and I hope that they
stop being friends with grandma's buzzy
Brooks what a weenie like have some
balls totally just like a weenie
response to make it political like our
privacy is celebrity but oh sure it's
just the idea that if you're in the
public eye in whatever capacity that you
are just sort of giving up your autonomy
and your privacy anywhere that you can't
go to a movie theater
you give up your pride yeah when you
were like hi I'm Greta Gerwig night most
people having people having no autonomy
or privacy has absolutely nothing to do
with them being celebrities nobody has
autonomy I take pictures of people that
I don't know on the train
I take the people take pictures of me
I'm sure like when they think that I'm
like oh look at those annoying girl like
that's just the society society we live
in people aren't taking pictures of you
because you're famous they're taking
pictures because you're an [ __ ]
screaming in a movie theater okay you
just happen to be famous right
oh and hardly famous like please like no
one knows who you are and your ugly
dress from the row that you wore to the
Met Gala she said I don't know maybe I'm
part of the problem because I do this
when I share so much but I don't think
that's it I mean I
think that it's up to the rest of us to
understand what privacy is and what
discretion is and to allow people to be
people okay so here's the thing if you
were to say that you have to say that on
behalf of people not celebrities because
these days nobody has any privacy so I
got it the FBI is watching you on your
webcam in the shower
interesting title that was like who's in
the wrong in this situation and first of
all Greta Gerwig is in the wrong for
being an [ __ ] and for not liking I
feel pretty and for talking during a
movie I would have clocked a [ __ ] like
one you're talking to her movie and to
in the quietest moment in the most
romantic scene like shut the [ __ ] up I
would have been so angry and then I
would have found out I was grad a girl
ray and I just give an extra yeah oh
this [ __ ] anyways now Busy Philipps has
joined herself in the wrong by blaming
this girl on twitter who did nothing
wrong except for trying cause if there's
a monster Greta Gerwig for the thirsty
[ __ ] that she is no literally Thank You
Jay hunt once again for delivering the
utmost premium content and I shouldn't
say I D I'm turning on her she would
come on her show and she never responded
damn what I would love to have her Oh
Jacob knows her Jacobs gonna get her on
the show okay he went to jail she went
to Jacobs high school like she just
seems like a funny girl no totally and
by the way Lea Michele did an Instagram
story the other day that like fully
proves she's illiterate she was doing a
fitting which I'd be [ __ ] and like put
up a picture of like this gorgeous rack
of clothes and she meant to write I'll
take them all and she wrote all take
them all alo I'll take them all well she
phrase overused Siri and said I'll take
them all on Siri set her doll but she
couldn't see the difference right
because she doesn't know letters
probably you know like the point of this
story about Busy Philipps is that nobody
has privacy not not celebrities only and
her privacy wasn't like disrupted she
was being disrupted and therefore made
herself a spectacle and got tweeted
about that is the world we live in
regardless of your celebrity or not and
please Greta Korea's hardly a celebrity
right that's true I'm surprised she
didn't recognize her would you write me
would you know if God worried because
I'm obsessed with like despising her I
don't know I think now I would after
this story I just was staring at a
picture of her next Busy Philipps I
think now I would know her face I know
that mug anyway she's more uh behind the
camera
woman right I don't know she directed
ladybird I've never seen any she's
really the only thing I know about her
no she's younger IMDB no please she was
in that other movie what if you found
out that she directed Legally Blonde I
mean that was just never happened like
that movie is so not on Greta girl right
which is why I love it okay tell me what
else do you think I know she doesn't
like one movie that like I've seen okay
The Adventures of oh no that's an ad
sorry okay
oh I love dogs have you what do you hear
about the movie I heard it was
incredible I didn't never even heard of
it up until right now is that cartoon
movie is Wes Anderson you probably saw
preview for it okay she was in 20th
century woman she was in Jackie yes
that's how I know her she she was a
Jackie O like like helpless it stopped
yeah it should took care of the game
with Jackie O say what I mean oh my god
apparently that's how she really spoke
but I don't believe it she's also in the
Mindy project wiener-dog Maggie's plan
China Illinois
I think Portland di mistress America How
I Met Your dad blah blah blah whole
bunch of nothing no fish you catch
another heart
oh you mean you mean friends v benefit
and that's pretty much it I'm sweating
she's 5 9 which is 1.75 meters do they
put their weights on them
I'm just curious maybe that's on IMDB
Pro oh for sure Jacob has a login so
we'll do that okay I'm not caught up on
Jersey Shore because I was working and
being an entertainer last night so I
promise this weekend I'm going to catch
up on Jersey Shore and I'm gonna catch
up on Riverdale and we're gonna die even
though some [ __ ] spoiled different
anyway I have an idea because the after
nail the calls for after day are oh we
are out of control so I think we should
all catch up on Riverdale next week's
the season finale and I think we should
do an episode of recap Riverdale yeah
and maybe like probably not for this
show cuz not every watch shows read
about me on the patreon like okay me you
snitch been like Oh G squad the og
getting burned out together yeah okay so
that would be really fun because I do
want to know what everyone thinks up
yeah okay I haven't seen it like I'm
really behind it's like the second half
of the season was so much better than
the first happened like when we were
weak having the first half it was like
we were pulling out straws yeah yeah but
now it's just like there's so much going
on there's so much recapping that needs
to be done yes someone needs to explain
it to us
okay well that's our show you guys we
are the morning toast we are alive
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time every week today we go live on
Facebook we live on YouTube and then we
upload the audio afterwards it's a
podcast so you should really make sure
you're subscribed to our YouTube page
and giving this video a thumbs up
you should also should also make sure
you like our Facebook page premium
content being delivered follow us on
Instagram at the morning show so and
then subscribe to our podcast the
Morning Joe sleep 5 stars would comment
about how like radiant gorgeous and
amazing in it and skinny we are it do
you want to it's ok skinny um and we
will see you guys on Monday see you on
Monday have a great weekend see you next
fall